[Music]
in gangster baby news
hey submitted by drinking my water I do
I do
double fisted [ __ ] mmm you gotta do
the dollar I mean your mouth isn't in
your mouth
oh no I just can't be a freakin freak
because it's graphics it's something
something but he calls it a [ __ ] [ __ ] him
creating it as [ __ ] hospital staff was
fired after a disturbing video of a
newborn is posted on Facebook I just
want where they call it devil child yeah
just Layton devil one can't just roast a
babe
picking on a baby you do anything worth
roasting no they're just nurses or
something right yo Terry nurses Navy can
I see this so these Navy nurses which
Navy uh Somalia maybe China
Nate no Merkin American baby at the
Naval Hospital Jacksonville Florida yeah
so these there was a video that was
posted on snapchat where a nurse is seen
forcing a newborn baby to dance to fifty
cents know your mother now I'd be so
cool if you were just chilling at the
baby okay another song yeah that's a
real abuse yeah terrible song no cuz
part another to his own kid that [ __ ]
leg and arm wave
the knowledge of the parents knowing
that this is happening kid already knows
your smell so they've already bonded
with you like that is oh really [ __ ] oh
my god military and medical all these
military nurses like popping out baby
this [ __ ] do they know they're taking
care like I mean helping helping people
popping out like is it because the
babies is this like that base like where
it wears is you know very base well
these are military wives babies I'm just
trying to figure out the source of baby
I think so cuz these are navy nurses
that work in regular hospital probably
uh military babies and the military
nurses on a military base yeah yeah it's
just military world yeah would you break
the law if you knew that was happening
to tyka what do you mean like the
[ __ ] [ __ ] up oh yeah yeah I'll [ __ ]
them up yeah I think I would too I'll
make them faster 50 cents yeah just all
bloody and [ __ ] that's [ __ ] up it's
really punk huh yeah so these nurses
they have been fired good they should
get their [ __ ] this also has a parent
like I do that would take all the time
but you can kind of feel how sturdy they
are yes when they come out they're like
limp and like a bag of jell-o so your
extra delicate but now like you kind of
feel like oh there's some structure so
now it's dance time mm-hmm
I saw the dance video so cute but it's
just their feet right let's just
apparently in the video shoot some here
people laughing and joking around with
someone behind the camera thing we're
going to help I feel like I hope they do
I don't have a kid but just like
imagining that I could just picture
myself just pummeling this person up
face and not stopping yeah just over and
over and over cuz that's like dude just
seeing them give give like tike of
there's like first shots I was like
cuz I'm Maggie too cuz like remember you
were mentioning to like you said the
whole experience of watching Taikan was
like falling in love for the first time
yeah so you had that emotion there and
then you see somebody [ __ ] with your
kid like how would you you probably just
[ __ ] lose it you see red yeah how
come her mom's not around well they
probably took to clean it up yeah my mom
can't follow the moms like recovering I
[ __ ] magnifying glass that [ __ ] right
can the husband fall oh yeah yeah when
she was recovering I would follow the
baby to do all their initial rounds and
stuff but the moms are like depending on
the labor the parties would be with him
the whole time or was there a moment
where you get the whole time in the room
because I think I remember they took on
the way oh well cuz he was a serious
situation I guess I can say how do you
know if it's the same baby we're back I
did have like a split like doubt I'm
just thankful to just like it are you
the same that should be happening
switching babies [ __ ] yeah they do
they're actually careful a place that
Tycho is born there's a wrist like
little tad thing and ankle one just so
do they like tag on as soon as the dad
hadlen the mom had one like everyone had
they're always checking like every three
hours or like checking barkos and on but
the chuck-e-cheese blacklights Tamplin I
would have let I wouldn't let the baby
go away I my sight you I can't wait for
you to be a dad why character to begin
with and then I know how protected you
can be as a person so it's like I'm yeah
exactly together it's like I don't like
to see that I feel like that baby would
never have clothes on just a cape I
think your baby yeah the key all time
like boogers on his face no shoes no
clothes on yeah yeah
and the third daughter pushpin all of my
animals have been very clean and nice
and well groomed and well fed yeah
you're a good doggie dad like this cute
little jungle book kid but like so cute
just just some hair sticking everywhere
it really long enough so cute what is
like the complete opposite it's a
complete gentleman
hair ku number two's face class beauty
irons his own clothes and [ __ ] because
I'm creating sleep comes up with you
know my kids are all I mean that's what
they did back in a day you popped out
all these kids so they work on the world
like 30 years ago
let me so cute he comes up to you hey
miss no 1980 yeah not 30 years ago I
wonder if your guy if taiko is gonna be
super proper or if he's gonna be like
wild I have no idea like you never know
you know I mean they take after their
parents that they can completely be
removed from the parents or they skip a
generation and they're like a
grandparent they have one of each a
while doing and a proper one no parent
that's right oh really like each of your
grandparents no no no I'm very proper I
thought you meant like youryour parents
had like one proper and one well yeah
when are you my dad is wild my mom was
proper good that's that's the weird
thing both my peers weld and I came out
boring oh you're not that boring that
was work that was work though you know
boring I just never I never been drank
or smoked like they did you know I mean
your name's Gina darling like I got my
name is [ __ ] that's why I'm singer and
you kept it I know you can change it's
too late everyone knows me like that not
looking to eat that name man why'd you
keep it because I don't know could you
change it to Gina was Gina just call me
Gina
everybody just Gina that's Gina - Gina
Unova yeah no but that like compared to
my parents like like my mom especially
my mom she still parties she's like come
on man do the color run with me I'm like
no she got you babe yeah come on anyway
she's got an active - she's gonna do the
Color Run yeah she does the Color Run
she does right runs like I'm afraid to
go to any of those cuz I'm working - my
mom just with her bottle of Hennessy you
know I'm like no leave me alone I'm
thinking she likes to party she does
maybe because she's like that it turned
to you that's why I'm not like she likes
to run and [ __ ] right
the first thing she'll do is choose a
drink ice water and not get winded
probably but that's what she does she'll
be like why are you so fat huh I do yoga
and I run now [ __ ] you mamas come on you
like yourself fat now how come I have a
six-pack I weigh less than you you know
how she's in competition look how much I
realize I've jumped into such a [ __ ]
physical [ __ ] I was watching like a
biting documentary right and I forgot
that when you're training you're
supposed to be in pain I mean like
there's like you're like like fighters
like they purposely do the oxygen
deprivation and that's what is supposed
to be like but in my mind I'll tell
myself you're not supposed to do that
it's not working out but that's how much
my - skewed right think that's not what
working out supposed to be they're
supposed to do that it's supposed to
train you for something I think he's
begging for you to train him no I must
say no I must say that at all he wants
to go on the Asian grandma workout plan
yeah
Piper oh [ __ ] you should give his like
type this grandma like that workout no
like I'm in water oh yeah you should get
very dedicated an hour for like teaching
a class at at your gym just mama Kwan's
advisers and [ __ ] noise workouts are
pretty crazy I love that that's so funny
that she doesn't know that her use of
energy is what makes her tired not her
heart being bad or whatever yeah because
she moves so [ __ ] much she's got all
this energy yeah yeah anyways back to
these these [ __ ] nurses oh yeah those
people here you could see one of the
nurses [ __ ] I like it live for like
an hour or like it has been out for an
hour it's already getting fingers thrown
at it like that sucks man I think the
early as middle finger ever to be
positive though that baby is gonna be a
great dancer when they grow up
potentially needles cuz its traumatize
great a 50 cent
yeah we're messed up shoulders like a
hound ruff you know she was holding it
like this to not like have you seen
those [ __ ] videos of women doing baby
gymnastic yoga's she'll toss them and
then catch them and no because if
they're like one no no newborns and then
she's good for their muscles and joints
it's [ __ ] crazy ever [ __ ] do that
to my baby what's Gary Moore they let
their babies float on their back in the
water oh that's a swimming I see footage
of babies underwater actually swimming
yeah
few months old yeah that's a natural for
them natural instinct to swim and that's
alone and water too yeah if you call
that water yes no not literally water
it's sewer drainage actually can I just
say well colors the liquid that comes
out when you pop your water bag uh I
don't know because because she pop it
like oh [ __ ] this might be TMI but Tyco
actually poop like his first poop was in
the room so it came out like oh wow
inside you yeah how did you clean out
all that [ __ ] what's not literally into
it's in the placenta oh so then when the
placenta comes out it's just there
meconium my friend that baby had that
and then choked on it and they couldn't
breathe for a little bit that happens I
mean he didn't eat his own [ __ ]
thank God but yeah it's called meconium
hey guys would you think of that video I
know you loved it so make sure to hit
that like button to watch more videos
and check it out up here
[Music]